hey pascal uh um obviously
not the end of the season that you guys
wanted but like it's
been just like a very strange bizarre or
very very long season for you guys can
you
just kind of reflect on on everything
that's kind of happened
um i mean i think you know it's tough um
i think you know we
we're hanging there we're hung in there
all trying to um find ways and
and um at the end of the day like you
know obviously like i have to be better
you know
definitely a long moment for me just
learning learning experience and
you know just knowing that you got to be
ready and um
you know i wasn't i wasn't able to
really help my teammates and stuff so
yeah i take a lot of the blame man i
think a lot of the blame just you know
continue to work like it's
a work it's a learning experience for me
continue to learn um
you know get back to the joining boards
and um come back better
um and that's something that i've always
been able to do as a player so
i got to just go back and figure it out
i think we had we had great chances you
know we hung in there trying to find
ways to win the games
that we played um obviously i felt like
i wasn't like i didn't really give you
know what was expected for me
and uh you know yeah i definitely take a
lot of that blame and but but i think
you know
as a team we played well and and we we
fought like that's something that we did
we always did it you know all season um
even when things weren't going well you
know we always you know taught
until the end and i'm proud of those
guys and i think you know everyone gave
everything that they had
um and like i said obviously like i you
know i gotta be better
you mentioned that you you trying to
take the blame for for this loss
uh did that have to do with like more
pressure
perhaps uh like like this this season i
know you've been in post-seasons past
but this was this postseason any
different um i mean not really i mean i
think obviously it was it wasn't it
wasn't like a normal season or
just having you know like the break and
all that um
at the end of the day there's no excuses
um we all pros and you have to be ready
and
i just you know i don't think it was
anything pressure-wise you know i just
feel like
um i wasn't at my best and
and one of my best i'm i'm my best you
know this team is unbelievable so
um you know you got you got to be at
your best at these times and i
felt like i wasn't thanks a lot pascal
and then thanks for kind of putting up
with us all season long
uh next we'll go to ryan walstad from
the toronto sun
hey pascal um obviously offseason
there's a lot of free agents on this
team
how much have you thought about it all
about you know obviously it's a business
and what's gonna happen obviously you've
been with fred your whole time and
you're very close with him have you
thought at all about potentially
um you know this might have been the
last hurrah with this group
um you know i really haven't thought
about it but obviously just knowing you
know that
um you know it's a business and
everything that's happening and
you know you can't really you know
there's just like
you know there's there's no way to kind
of plan in your head or or try to figure
out i think you just go with the flow
and
and obviously those guys that we have
you know unbelievable um
you know the love that i have for those
guys i mean obviously freddie
of my best friends and all the guys mark
just heard you know um
you know great guys great people that um
i've learned a lot from and
um so yeah like hopefully you know we
you know we
kind of have the same people but at the
end of the day like i don't really have
no control over that
um and we always murder start the other
day and um
obviously i love those guys
thank you uh next we'll go to c rat from
yahoo sports
hey pascal um how does it feel to uh to
feel
responsible for for this outcome
i mean i think you know at the end of
the day like
it's just it's part of being in this
league and being at the level that i'm
supposed to be at
um obviously it's a learning experience
and
and like i said you know a lot of people
go through these moments
and um i just feel like it's about
responding you know
what what response are you going what
response are you going to get from it
um how are you going to take it are you
going to take it as a learning
experience or are you just going to
feel sorry for yourself because at the
end of the day nobody's going to feel
sorry for you
um and and i you know i come from a
background of you know just always
working hard and
and finding my way through everything
that was thrown at me
and i just felt like this is another
step it's another step
came in the league wasn't you know i
wasn't supposed to be here but
you know i i i [ __ ] my way here and
and
i proved that i belong and and obviously
you know um
it's something that i have to continue
to work on continue to do continue to
prove every single day and
um and and like i said it's another step
for me
um something that i'm gonna go back and
and you know obviously
losing sucks um and but but this
is it's an experience and um
all the greats go through it and you
have to learn from it um if you want to
be
considered one of the best players you
know you have to be able to um
rise from this these moments and um
that's something that you know
i plan to do does it give you a little
more confidence
to to think about your journey where you
came from
i mean like i said obviously i i come
from you know um
like i said i i wasn't supposed to be
here a lot of people didn't see me here
um
and and and i proved a lot of people
wrong obviously
um didn't play the way that i expected
to play um
but but i i always have you know those
high expectations for myself like i
don't really
like it doesn't like really matter what
other people think to me like i
i have this position for myself because
i always saw myself as somebody that
um could be you know a really good
player in this league
and um and and i worked hard you know i
work hard every single day i work hard
every single day and
and i put myself in these situations and
um and you have to continue to learn
you have to continue to learn and like i
said that's something that you know
i take i take my chin up um
move forward continue to work hard um
go back watch it find ways to be better
and um
you know and and and learn from it
that's all i can do
and um obviously there's a lot more
years in this league and
i feel like you know um i can only go up
something from here
thanks pascal next we'll go to mike
ganter from the toronto sun
hey pascal um every time your name got
mentioned or your struggles got
mentioned on these zoom calls
your your teammates and your coaches
came to your defense
what what was it like behind the scenes
that support for you
um it's unbelievable man those guys um
they they have my back and um you know
from everyone in the organization you
know they always support me
and um and for me like i said it's part
of the journey
it's part of the journey and it's
something that um years down the line
i'm gonna look at him
and you know um and i'm just gonna be
like man like look where you came
you know look how far you came and look
what you did and um
so it's unbelievable to have that type
of support you know just it just means a
lot and
i really appreciate it for sure got it
thanks pascal
uh next we'll go to bruce arthur from
the toronto start
pascal this is such tough end of what
has been a really marvelous season for
you
when you look back at the whole thing um
the beginning and the end
um what are you proud of and what do you
maybe regret about how it ended
obviously you want to be able to you
know get there to the end like
that was always the goal for us and and
obviously disappointing
um and and for me
personally you know it's just um
i think i learned a lot man i learned a
lot i went through a lot
and and like i said it wasn't normal
circumstances and
i tried to fight fight my way through it
um i just didn't have it you know i
didn't play well
i didn't i didn't really you know help
my teammates as much as i i could have
but you know one thing that i did is i
gave it all out there you know i played
hard
that's something i almost i always want
to do and um and
i have to live with the results i have
to deal with the results and um and
that's that's something that like i said
i've been talking about
is just you know continue to learn and
when you look back at the pandemic and
everything after
um what was the most challenging part of
it the pandemic and the bubble for you
i think for me maybe the most
challenging part was you know just
that time where you know i didn't i
didn't really have
somewhere to go to work hard at and um i
was stuck in canada i couldn't i
couldn't travel to the us
because of visa issues but um but at the
end of the day you know i did everything
that i could you know being home having
all the stuff to stay in shape um but
you know obviously like
i think i gave it all out there and and
and i labeled the results like man like
i
um i worked so hard that you know at the
end of the day like
i'm just gonna always put it all out
there and
whatever result come out of it you know
i have to take it if it's good you know
um
everything's good but if it's not good
let's just continue to learn
do you think not touching the ball as
much as you wanted in the pandemic is
that
what led to maybe this series and today
in the playoffs
i mean i can't tell i can't say i can't
say i think
i think i was here um there's no excuse
and um when you're out there on the
floor you have to perform
at your highest and um and obviously you
know i didn't do that most of the
playoffs so
um it's based on me thank you pascal
safe travels home
uh the last question in english will go
to john scott from tnt who i think is
there in person
go ahead john so this has happened since
being here in the nba bubble so as the
journey comes to an end we're just
asking players it was their last words
to recap the nba mobile experience i
mean
obviously you know um being safe
obviously that's the first thing that
like being healthy
um and i know a lot of people are going
through a lot right now and
and um you know just keeping them in in
our prayers and
and the lead to the facilities job to
you know have this this thing working
and having people play basketball and
having people um
enjoy basketball so you know
this is definitely one experience you
know of a lifetime and
and something that we never thought
would happen um so
yeah amazing job by the nba and i'll
continue hopefully you know just
continue to work today